(casting)
Imagine going from back-to-back relegation
tournaments, and fighting for survival in
your own league, to winning the entire thing.
Well you don’t have to imagine.
I’m Colin McNeil, and today we’re talking
about Team Liquid’s 2018 NA LCS Spring Split
run.
Now, if you’re a TL fan already, I don’t need to tell
you, the boys in blue have not always had
it easy.
That’s why our story starts last year, in
two very unsuccessful splits for Team Liquid.
(casting)
But things were looking up in 2018.
First, Team Liquid secured that coveted franchise
spot in the new league.
And
the hype surrounding Doublelift, Pobelter,
Impact, Xmithie, and Olleh, meant the
team
was coming in hot to
the spring split.
And, at least at first, they did not disappoint.
(casting)
Now, it was around week 4 however, if you remember, that the shine came off Team Liquid.
They faced down their first 0-2 week in the split,
and the following weeks had them find consistently
inconsistent results.
(casting)
Now much to the relief of Team Liquid fans everywhere, it was in week 9 against
Cloud9 they locked in that playoff spot.
(casting)
Okay, so TL squeaks into the playoffs, but they get in.
Facing down the likes of TSM, Cloud9, 100 Thieves and Echo Fox though, things were not going to be easy.
(casting)
Personal tragedy struck Doublelift before the grand finals, and there were some questions as to whether
or not he'd be able to play in them or not.
Well he did play.
And he was lights out.
In fact, the entirety of Team Liquid hit the rift like players possessed.
They 3-0'd 100 Thieves, sweeping them, in the grand final.
(casting)
And that's how they did it.
That's how Team Liquid broke their curse.
They weren't fourth anymore.
They raised their banner, lifted the trophy and became the fourth ever team to win  NA LCS.
The fourth.
Sh-t.